For decades, the United States has had one of the most open markets in the world...
...and that openness has helped to fuel the success of so many countries in this region...
...and others over the last century.
In this new era, opening other markets around the globe will be critical not just to America's prosperity,...
...but to the world's as well.
An integral part of this new strategy is working towards an ambitious and balanced Doha Agreement.
Not any agreement, but an agreement that will open up markets and increase exports around the world.
We are ready to work with our Asian partners to see if we can achieve that objective in a timely fashion.
And we invite our regional trading partners to join us at the table.
We also believe that continued integration of the economies of this region...
...will benefit workers, consumers and businesses in all our nations.
Together with our South Korean friends,...
...we will work through the issues necessary to move forward on a trade agreement with them.
The United States will also be engaging with the Trans-Pacific Partnership countries...
...with the goal of shaping a regional agreement that will have broad-based membership...
...and the high standards worthy of a 21st century trade agreement.
Working in partnership, this is how we can sustain this recovery and advance our common prosperity.
But it's not enough to pursue growth that is balanced.
We also need growth that is sustainable.
For our planet and the future generations that will live here.